what about the people that say we're
seeing the beginning of the next big
extinction event
it's so stupid
we're not seeing the beginning of the
next big extinction event
okay if a big extinction event was
happening and it was being documented i
could get it but read the chapter in my
book on extinction where i appeared
before
a committee of the u.s house of congress
with three people there claiming to be
united nations scientists
saying that yes
we only know of 1.7 plus million species
which have been identified named
photographed written up etc but there
are very likely 8.7 million species
that's what they said
there's probably 8.7 million species and
this is our best estimate
where did they get that estimate thin
air there's no way you can turn one
point 1.7 into 8.7
without having any actual observation of
any real thing
so they were saying there's about seven
million
unreal species that we don't know about
and then they say and a million of those
will go extinct in the next few decades
right how many of you how many of the
observed creatures
have they seen go extinct
an ever decreasing number
as humans in around 1920 when the
passenger pigeon became extinct
suddenly
the general population took an interest
in the issue of extinction
prior to that which wasn't very long ago
100 years
nobody cared about extinction they
thought it was a normal thing except a
few naturalists who
bemoaned the extinction of the dodo bird
or other species that went extinct as a
result of human activity
and most people don't realize that the
main cause
of species extinction is not hunting
right it is actually agriculture
and the changing of habitats
so that is why most
species recovery programs are based on
habitat
and making sure that there's a place for
these species to exist
that's key
but we have not like overrun 90 percent
of the world's habitat and much of the
area that we are using especially for
forestry
is perfectly suitable for most of the
species that always lived in the forest
agriculture is different
agriculture creates a monoculture on
purpose and that's pretty hard to get
away from people who preach that you
should have 17 different species of
plants growing on the same plot of land
i'd like to see them do it successfully
it's not possible
so they the farmer wants to get rid of
every insect every animal
you know everything other than every
other plant all other all other plants
are weeds
in this case
and so agriculture is is where you have
to really
look at what you're doing in the
landscape and make sure that in that
landscape and it usually happens
naturally if you fly across the uh
whole agricultural area of the united
states you see lots of forest
interspersed among the agricultural land
because and
europe too i mean most people don't
realize that 200 years ago 250 years ago
less than 10 percent of europe remained
forested because the trees were being
used for everything to do with fuel they
were being used to heat all the
buildings to smelt all the iron and
copper to do the glassworks
and steam engines everything was fueled
by wood and all the building of
everything so forests started to
disappear in central europe initially
and then spreading out over the whole of
europe the first time in the history of
humans where forests
were disappearing we were cutting them
faster than they were growing back
that's why agriculture was invented 10
000 years ago and forestry wasn't
invented until about 1750 in central
europe because they realized they had to
start planting some trees
and then silviculture otherwise known as
as as forestry scientific forestry came
into being and now there's 43 forest
cover in europe well speaking of trees i
thought i thought the amazon rainforest
was wrecked
ten percent of it has been modified
that's going a lot that could be quite a
bit it's a fair big forest isn't it
it's a huge forest and it's not in any
way endangered
the the problem with you know my book is
titled fake invisible catastrophes and
threats of doom for a reason i put the
word invisible in there
because to most people the amazon is
invisible they show you a picture of a
fire that takes up the whole screen
right it might be about 10 feet
of the you know of the amazon which is
almost as big as the continental united
states brazil itself is almost as big as
the continental united states and amazon
is a huge part of brazil
and
there are parts of the amazon
that have been developed
but most of it is intact
and even where it's been developed it is
only small areas if you just look at a
satellite photograph of it you can see
it i've flown over it in an airplane at
fairly low elevation and you go for five
hours and you hardly see any people
it's called a human desert by people but
even
you know the the leader of brazil now is
under attack over the amazon
from the left
and one of the reasons you can get away
with that is almost no one in brazil has
ever been to the amazon even though it's
in their own country
people don't go there
what would you do there
it's got manaus which is basically a
manufacturing hub for electronics so
it's a sort of a
tax-free zone of some kind
you've got bailam at the mouth of the
river which is i've been to that city
it's not very interesting it's just a
city at the mouth of the amazon and
there's not much else to do there
you can go on a boat up and down the
river
then you see all you see is trees the
whole way and the amazon
is 300 miles wide during the flood
period it will never have a bridge over
it
it doesn't have a road anymore because
the road the plants grew up through the
pavement and destroyed the road within
10 years when they did build one to
minnows i'm going to guess that if we
continue to increase the concentration
of carbon dioxide that's just going to
happen quicker
yes the amazon is is growing faster but
interestingly it's the drier places that
benefit most from increased co2
because
increased co2 has two effects
one more co2 for growth
like
i'll give you the second one in a minute
but first i digress to say that i used
to laugh at people who said their plants
grew better when they talked to them as
if plants have ears and can hear you and
are empathetic or whatever
and so i sort of chuckled at that then i
realized
that when you're talking to your plants
you're breathing 40 000 parts per
million
co2 on them that's our breath
is a hundred times the level it is in
the air
so you're basically breathing super
concentrated fertilizer onto your plants
when you're talking to them and they do
grow better because of that because they
would like to have more co2 than exists
in the natural world today
the second thing that increased co2 does
is it makes most plants more efficient
with water
because now it's easier for them to get
the carbon dioxide they need because
it's more concentrated in the atmosphere
and therefore they don't need to make as
many holes in the bottom of their leaves
they're called stomata
it's where they take in the air with the
co2 in it but it's also where they lose
water through transpiration
so the fewer of those holes there are
the less water they lose therefore the
more efficient they become with water
and gives them ability to survive in
places that have less water than they
could before that's why trees are
marching out onto grasslands in many
parts of the world the south west of the
us for example and australia
the very eastern part
of uh sorry the very western part of
australia western australia as it's
known
is the driest part of australia the
nalabar desert is there too which
doesn't have much of anything growing on
it because it's so dry but in the in the
west like around perth and down to
albany the the trees are growing much
faster now and so are the crops because
they you know if if you're a farmer
today and you are giving your plants all
the water
and all the fertilizer they need the
mineral food
the limiting factor to the plants growth
is carbon dioxide because of how low it
is in the atmosphere even today
and the proof is in the pudding here
because all commercial greenhouse
growers
in the world
inject carbon dioxide into their
greenhouses because they have an
enclosed space where they can increase
the level of co2 and they generally go
up to between 800 and 1200 ppm
which even above that the plants grow
faster but there's a curve because
economics is involved they have to buy
the co2 so at this level at right
somewhere in the curve they say okay
1200 is optimum for us because above
that buying more co2 has an ever
decreasing increase in yield
and so 1200 works really well in
greenhouses that's four times sorry
three times what it is today in the
global atmosphere and that is
we should not even be concerned
until co2 gets up to 20 000 ppm
because that's what submariners survive
in for three months underwater
and the
the people who uh had the trouble on
apollo 13 where the co2 was building up
it went up to at least 20 000 in there
see our breath is 40 000. we have forty
thousand ppm co2 in our lungs just
before we breathe out i don't wanna be
breathing that in though
yes you do
but the same air that i breathed out
well in that case you can't just once
just once yeah yeah but you don't want
to be a closed system of breathing that
back in when you put your mask on you
are breathing a significant portion of
the air you just breathed out back in
again
so
we we we can survive at a whole
different bunch of levels of co2 just
fine and plants are happy with it at 10
000 ppm or they wouldn't be here because
that's what it was back 500 million
years ago what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you